when you go through a situation like
what you went through
it has to kind of put things in
perspective
does it kind of give you like a
does it check you to kind of re re check
what your priorities are in life
yeah man how are you living i used to be
living reckless you feel me just
straight up i'm gonna keep it 100 but
now it's like a
have a certain couple of people with me
then my extra eyes
we in and out you feel me ain't no
lollygagging
as far as drinking liquor drinking
around my homies not being belligerent
in public because
people you don't know yeah that's where
you get caught slipping
up a lot of things bro yeah i feel like
um
when you got shot i was like [ __ ] i feel
like i just saw you in san diego
like not too far before i was like damn
i hope the homie
pulls through you getting shot
i feel did you did you um cause when
something like that happens to you in
life
you're gonna get a lot of people hitting
you up who might not have been talking
to you prior
did you notice some
some some some fake energy [ __ ] coming
around like during that time
because whenever some [ __ ] like that
happens i feel like
everybody's gonna come out the woodworks
make sure they check in yeah
but it's like where were you at like a
month ago type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
i feel like um you know that come with
this rap [ __ ] you for me
that's a rap game half of the [ __ ] fake
but for the most part you send me my
real ones that i already had songs with
or
really no personal without even having
songs they
texted me you said i'm saying my phone
is off at that moment but when i got
back home
i turned it on this [ __ ] started ringing
it's like all right i like that from the
people that i really mess with
thoroughly
but um you know all the the rap [ __ ] now
you feel me
i pulled through pull through i'm
highlighting your blood and
that's the fake [ __ ] so it's 50 50 man
and
i try to weed it off you know what i
mean by this being respectful but
knowing that they gonna [ __ ] with me
like that or like you weren't even
caring about my situation or even what i
was doing
prior to this you feel me so i'm taking
around with it man
yeah man i feel like the rap game is so
finicky man
it's a lot of associates but not a you
know what i'm saying lot of
like in this game bro not like that but
you don't got no friends in this game
you already know what it is you see you
might see someone at the club be like yo
let's do something and you never hear
from him
my [ __ ] until you run into him again
until you run into him again do the same
[ __ ]
yeah let's say you know what it is that
should happen a lot that [ __ ]
man look i don't do that [ __ ] that's why
that's what's the difference between me
and other people was like
i hold it down and make it make my word
of like what i'm gonna say i'm gonna do
i'ma do it you feel me like
like a lot of people just you know they
just i just talk a good one
so get take me back to the moment you
got shot man because i feel like that's
got to be a pivotal moment it was
anyone's life when someone tries to take
your life and you survive
how did like you know what do you
recollect from that day
like that moment that all the crazy [ __ ]
i was doing like i said
loaded riding around the city just
for nothing you feel me i was just
coming from my folks house
but i could have left i got a freeway
and got to go got the [ __ ] out
yeah yes that he wanted to just ride
around and i don't know like with some
myth to happen it's going to happen so i
was over there and
you know what i mean and that should ha
it happened like that and
my life was just flat before my eyes bro
i've seen people that i
really be cool with really hanging with
family members it's just
like i blacked out you feel me like from
the gun shells and i'm just seeing my
life like
this crazy [ __ ] but it's like
it's like that's when you see the light
you think that's what's crazy is they
always say
right before you there's a um some [ __ ]
called
uh dimensionally what
what is dmt i don't know what dmc stands
for but there's a chemical called dmt
you you have it
when you're born and right before you
die and it's supposed to like
when people say they see the light
that's supposed to be what they see
yeah and it's a there there's a way you
could smoke there's like
you could smoke dmt to feel that
now if you wanted to to try to like go
through some [ __ ] did you feel like when
you come out on the other side of it
you're in the hospital bed
did you feel like you went through some
[ __ ] that kind of maybe
changed your life yeah like
at that moment i think about my daughter
he's going to say my mama
my close friends peers it's like damn
it could be over here so i'm saying so
it's
it's a mind thing you feel me going
through that and i bounced out of it and
i just told myself like the ignition i
was doing i'mma stop
i got to be more like like hands-on
about my life you said i'm saying and i
just
[ __ ] like fun and games and i mean like
[ __ ] is real and that [ __ ] would have
been over like it was over
all this [ __ ] i worked for all this you
know i mean i got my daughter just like
of course of course
so i know now you know i mean like do
the right thing
it's not [ __ ] off you feel me